russia's brutal war in ukraine at least
18 health care providers have been hit
by russian attacks since the start of
the conflict including this maternity
and children's hospital in the coastal
city of mariopo this video from
ukrainian military appears to show their
forces repelling a russian armored
convoy outside of keith
one u.s official estimates up to six
thousand russian troops may have been
killed so far two weeks into the war
vice president kamala harris is in
warsaw this morning the capital of
poland where more than a million
ukrainians have crossed the border to
escape the fighting she announced the
u.s is giving 50 million dollars to help
those refugees christina raffini has
been following this refugee crisis from
the beginning she is in the southeastern
city of jesha christina good morning to
you tell us what you're seeing there
good morning nancy well for many people
who get here getting out is just the
beginning they don't know exactly where
they're going or where to wait before
the next leg of their journey that's
where an american paratrooper on
vacation in poland jumped in to help
the train station in shemesh is full of
unexpected departures missed connections
and delays
but in a crowded corner armed with a
cardboard sign in google translate
russian to english u.s army captain
sebastian connor is carrying out his
self-appointed mission
finding rooms for refugees in transit
the only way i could think of to
actually help these people was to get
hotels and put them in a place where
they could get a hot shower
and a bed so this is how you're spending
your vacation
now it is
yeah
connor was on leave in poland visiting
the nazi death camp at triplinka when
the russian assault happened
instead of taking his planned flight to
ireland he grabbed a train to this town
near the ukrainian border and started
booking every hotel room he could find i
saw that human tragedy i saw this
unfolding and i was like i can't i can't
do nothing doesn't make any sense
these four women and six-year-old adam
came from kiev their train for warsaw
didn't leave until the next day so
instead of sleeping at the station they
followed conor about 15 minutes through
cold cobblestone streets to this hostel
where they get four beds free of charge
did you think you would have to leave no
i did
even yesterday i didn't know if i should
leave
or i should stay yes
mother brother
father
of my other friends stay
here
there and um we cry
we cry very very cry all cry
when
trey and go uh
all
all try and cry might be the whole train
is crying
in the face of overwhelming uncertainty
knowing where they're going to sleep
tonight they said helps
and for this night that's enough
now conor had to go as leave is up but
he's handed the effort over to some
local polish volunteers who are going to
keep filling those hotel rooms he's
booked up he's also got a gofundme
account that's raised more than three
thousand dollars nate
christina rafini in poland thank you
when you see human tragedy yes on the
opposite end you see the best in
humanity connor said i saw this tragedy
i couldn't do anything he said i was
looking for them to get a hot shower in
the bed that's exactly what we want on
vacation right which is what he was on
and decided to do more for people that
needed it so much uncertainty for these
refugees and then you think about the
tens of thousands of people who want to
get out of ukraine and cancer right
heartbreaking yeah heartbreaking for
sure but shout out to connor though on
vacation doing something for people in
need